[Music]
it's time for et's social study your
quick look at what the stars are posting
online Sarah Hyland took to Instagram to
wish her Modern Family co-star Arielle
winter a happy birthday
sweetly saying in the caption the little
sister I always wanted but never had
everyone had the bike Arielle rang in
her 19th by posting this cheeky shot to
the gram this is a tough one
Serena Williams celebrated winning the
2017 Australian Open by defeating her
sister Venus in the women's singles
final on Saturday by posting this sweet
photo of the two hugging it out writing
in the caption the top is never lonely
when your best friend is there what a
night for our family Miho wasa Tom Brady
Joshy
Suzu ahead of next week's Super Bowl Tom
Brady wished his fans a happy Chinese
New Year on Facebook posting a video of
himself speaking in Mandarin was Ed
Sheeran
took to Twitter to tease fans something
seemingly music related will be released
Monday the shape of youth singer posted
a series of cryptic photos and videos of
himself in boxing gear meanwhile Rihanna
celebrated the anniversary of her album
anti by sharing behind-the-scenes pics
during the recording of it and Tina
Knowles shared this adorable mashup pic
of her daughter Beyonce and grand
daughter Blue Ivy who looks just like
her famous mother writing how cute is
this
[Music]